.
Liebe bedeutet sehr viel.
Aber am Ende muss man glücklich sein
und schauen,
was für sich selbst das Beste ist.
Wir haben noch nie
richtig gestritten.
Zuerst dachte ich nur:
"Wow, ist der gross!"
* Romantische Musik:
"Take My Hand" von Martin Villiger
und Adrian Stern *
# Take my hand. Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me.
# Take my hand.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Sonntag ist Familientag,
auch bei Claudia und Yakhouba -
oder Kub, wie ihn hier alle nennen.
Heute steigen sie mit ihren Töchtern
Ariana und Alessia
auf den Hausberg von Atlanta.
Er 2,01 m, sie 1,58 m.
Er Franzose, sie Schweizerin.
Seit zehn Jahren
sind sie verheiratet.
Neben den
offensichtlichen Gegensätzen
haben Claudia und Kub auch vieles
Gemeinsam, z.B. die Liebe zur Natur.
Es erinnert mich an die Schweiz -
das Wandern, die Aussicht, das Grün.
Es ist schön,
sonntags hierherzukommen,
und vor dem normalen Alltag
zu flüchten.
So normal ist ihr Alltag aber nicht.
Immerhin ist er ein Basketballprofi
und sie erfolgreiche Privatköchin
von Sportstars.
Alles ist etwas mehr -
ich kann kein Deutsch mehr -
convenient, etwas einfacher.
Es gibt mehr Möglichkeiten,
den Beruf auszuüben, den ich möchte.
Für uns ist es viel billiger,
hier zu wohnen.
Ein Business aufzubauen finde ich
hier einfacher als in der Schweiz.
Und dass sie in den USA deutlich
weniger auffallen als bei uns,
ist v.a. ihm gerade recht.
In der Schweiz werde ich angestarrt,
weil ich so gross bin,
hier ist das völlig normal.
Für mich war es immer okay
in der Schweiz.
Wenn ich mit ihm in der Schweiz bin,
sagen die Leute: "Ui,
so ein grosser, schwarzer Mann."
Im Bus
halten sie ihre Tasche fest.
Ja, das ist schon
ein bisschen anders.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Kinderstimmen) Wow!
* Stimmengewirr *
* Herzschlag *
Ich habe nie daran gedacht.
Ich hatte vorher nie eine Partnerin
aus einem anderen Land,
es war nie ein Thema.
Es ist einfach geschehen.
Ich Glücklicher.
Ich hatte auch schon Partner,
die aus einem anderen Land stammten,
aber in der Schweiz lebten.
Damals prallten verschiedene
Mentalitäten aufeinander.
Ich habe diese Erfahrung
also mitgebracht.
Ich habe nie wirklich
negative Erfahrungen
mit anderen Mentalitäten gemacht.
Deshalb war ich
dem gegenüber sehr offen.
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
Florence war Flight-Attendant,
arbeitete bis vor Kurzem
als Tierpflegerin
und lebt mit ihrer jüngeren Tochter
Noya in Derendingen.
Die ältere Tochter Laura
ist ausgezogen
und kommt nur noch
hin und wieder zu Besuch.
Das ganze Haus.
- Ja.
Das ist deins?
Dafür leben in diesem grossen Haus
auch noch sieben Hunde.
Hallo, hallo.
Man weiss gar nicht,
wo man zuerst hinschauen soll.
Ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
* Jaulen *
Ja, so läuft das.
- Wirst du immer so begrüsst?
Nein.
Wie lange Florence noch hier wohnt,
weiss sie nicht.
Ihr Mann Niklas baut zurzeit
in seiner Heimat Schweden
ein Haus für sie und die Hunde.
Wie hat dein Mann reagiert, als er
zum ersten Mal zu dir nach Hause kam?
Er wusste es ja.
Aber er als Nichthundehalter -
er hatte auch noch nie einen Hund -
wusste schon nicht genau,
was auf ihn zukommt.
Aber er sagte, er habe es sich
schlimmer vorgestellt,
als es schlussendlich war.
Die Entscheidung zwischen ihm
und den Hunden wäre klar gewesen?
Ja.
- Wirklich?
- Ehrlich? Wow.
Die beiden lernten sich
über Facebook kennen.
Er suchte eine
Französisch-Dolmetscherin
und fand die Frau des Lebens.
Vor lauter Hunden ...
Ich bin Mona.
- Hallo, Laura, freut mich.
Noya, freut mich.
- Noya, Mona.
Die ältere Tochter,
die jüngere Tochter.
Genau, jawohl.
- Genau. Und die Mama. - Ja.
Die haben wir ja schon kennengelernt.
Ich fragte, wie der Mann reagierte,
als er die Hunde kennenlernte.
Wie habt ihr reagiert,
als eure Mutter sagte,
dass sie sich
in einen Schweden verliebt habe?
Am Anfang war es ziemlich komisch.
"Oh, jetzt kommt wieder
ein neuer Mann."
Aber als wir uns das erste Mal
sahen, hat es sofort gefunkt.
Wir verstanden uns super,
auch die Sprache war kein Problem.
Fast so, als wäre er Schweizer.
Sie hat ihn uns vorgestellt und wir
haben gemerkt, dass es ernst ist.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass er super zu uns passt.
Er ist gleich wie wir,
hat den gleichen Humor.
Es ist uns wichtig, dass wir
jemanden in der Familie haben,
der zur Familie passt
und mit uns harmoniert.
Wir hatten
keine Startschwierigkeiten.
Wie war es für dich am Anfang?
War es dir wichtig, was deine Töchter
über deinen Mann Niklas denken?
Ja, es ist sicher wichtig,
was sie von ihm halten.
Wenn sie finden würden,
dass er gar nicht passt ...
Aber so wie ich ihn kennenlernte,
wusste ich, dass seine Art passt.
Dann wohnt ihr hier zu zweit
wie in einer Frauen-WG?
Ja, mehr oder weniger.
Eine Hunde-WG
trifft es vielleicht eher.
Aber du möchtest die Hunde
alle mitnehmen nach Schweden.
Ja. Emma darf ich nicht mitnehmen.
Gell, Noya?
Nein, die bleibt bei mir!
Noya, hast du dir überlegt,
nach Schweden mitzugehen?
Nein, sehr wahrscheinlich
ziehe ich zu meinem Papa.
Vielleicht wohne ich auch alleine.
Ich weiss noch nicht genau,
wie ich es machen möchte.
Ob es geht. - Aber nach Schweden
ist keine Option, nein.
Warum nicht?
Alle meine Freunde sind hier,
mein Papa und die Oma.
Ich könnte nicht einfach so weggehen
und sie nur selten sehen.
Nein.
Wie sicher ist es,
dass du nach Schweden ziehst?
Aha. Also das ist schon ...
- ... das steht fest?
Das Haus, das Niklas jetzt baut,
ist so konzipiert ...
Es ist mitten im Wald,
ganz abgelegen.
Er sagt immer,
dass er nicht alleine dorthin zieht.
Er rechnet fest damit,
dass du kommst?
Ja, ja.
- Du gehst? In einem Jahr?
Ja, das kommt auf Noya an,
sie macht noch die Lehre.
Nicht mehr ganz anderthalb Jahre.
- Genau.
Es kommt auch darauf an,
wie es ihr sonst geht.
Du hast eine Angststörung,
kann man das so sagen?
Oder wie nennst du es?
- Doch, es ist eine Angststörung.
Das ist ja bestimmt ein grosses Thema
in deinem Leben.
Jetzt, da du weisst, dass
deine Mutter nach Schweden zieht,
wie ist das für dich?
Sie hilft mir oft.
Mit Problemen gehe ich zu ihr.
Das wäre sicher seltsam,
alleine zu wohnen.
Aber irgendwann
muss ich damit klarkommen.
Ja. Aber redet ihr darüber?
Merkst du, ob es ihr schwerfällt,
wegzuziehen?
Ja, das denke ich schon. Sie weiss,
dass ich das Problem habe.
Wenn sie in Schweden ist,
wird sie sich bestimmt fragen,
wie es mir gerade geht.
Das ist sicher auch ein Thema.
- Ja.
Aber wir reden sehr viel darüber,
wie es weitergeht.
Kannst du sie
einfach so gehen lassen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Für mich ist es nicht so ...
Klar werde ich sie vermissen,
aber es ist ihr Leben.
Wenn sie das möchte ...
Irgendwann würde ich
sowieso ausziehen
und sie nicht mehr oft sehen.
Ich bin in einem Alter,
in dem man das gut verkraften kann.
Ja.
Wie ist es für dich? Noya
und du seid sehr eng zusammen,
auch, weil sie diese Ängste hat.
Gleichzeitig weisst du,
dass du in einem Jahr gehen willst.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Das ist ein schwieriges Thema.
Man sieht einen Teenager mit 16, 17,
in seiner unbeschwerten Zeit,
der sich noch nicht viele Gedanken
und Sorgen machen müsste.
Und dann sieht man, wie sie
durch die Ängste blockiert ist.
Das ist hart als Mutter,
wenn man das sieht.
Man überlegt sich schon,
wie das in Zukunft sein könnte.
Wie kann sie damit umgehen?
Gibt es irgendwann ... eine Heilung?
Oder eher nicht?
Wie wird es für sie?
Das steht immer im Raum,
darüber macht man sich Gedanken.
Ich frage mich auch:
"Bin ich eine schlechte Mutter,
wenn ich trotzdem gehe?"
Für mich muss eine Lösung da sein,
bevor ich gehe.
Lösung klingt etwas blöd ...
Für Noya muss es stimmen.
Ich weiss genau, dass sich
alle Zuschauer jetzt fragen:
"Was bedeutet das, Angststörung?"
Man kann sich
so nichts darunter vorstellen.
Logisch, psychische Sachen
sieht man niemandem an.
Man würde es nicht von dir denken.
Das Letzte, was ich denken würde,
ist, dass du eine Angststörung hast.
Wie zeigt sich das bei dir?
Von aussen sieht man es nicht,
ausser wenn ich akute Symptome habe,
z.B. eine Panikattacke.
Zittern, Probleme mit der Atmung.
Solche Dinge.
Erst dann merkt man es,
so zeigt sich die Angst.
Ich finde es sehr cool,
dass du so offen darüber redest.
Ja ...
- Also, das ist auch nicht ...
Hast du das gelernt
oder fühlst du dich besser,
wenn die Leute es wissen?
Am Anfang schämte ich mich
etwas dafür.
Inzwischen habe ich eingesehen, dass
man sich dafür nicht schämen muss.
Es ist
wie bei jeder anderen Krankheit:
Man kann sie sich nicht aussuchen.
Ich schäme mich nicht mehr dafür.
* Brutzeln *
* Winseln *
* Perlende Klänge *
Danke fürs Kochen helfen.
Die Schweiz hat einen Riesenplatz
in meinem Herzen.
Sie ist der Ort,
an dem ich mich am wohlsten fühle,
wo ich alles verstehe, wo ich weiss,
wie alles funktioniert.
Die Natur, die Gerüche, die Klänge,
das sind alles so Dinge ...
Als ich nach einem halben Jahr
in Australien
in die Schweiz nach Buochs
zurückkam,
hörte ich wieder Kirchenglocken,
Flugzeuge - typisch für Buochs -
und ähm ...
... die Glocken der Kühe.
Das sind Dinge,
die einen zurückversetzen
und bei denen ich merke:
"Wow, ich liebe es hier!"
Man bekommt sofort
ein wohliges Gefühl.
"Hier bin ich zu Hause,
hier fühle ich mich wohl."
* Kirchenglocken *
Bei Familie Stutz, die ich jetzt
besuche, könnte man neidisch werden.
Alles ist picobello und schon
von Weitem riecht es nach Lebkuchen.
In das Zusammensein
mischt sich aber eine bittere Note.
Bald ist das so nicht mehr möglich.
Möchtet ihr noch ein Stück Kuchen?
Ihr könnt euch hinsetzen,
wenn ihr möchtet. - Vielen Dank.
Den Lebkuchen musst du probieren!
- Ist das die Spezialität?
Es gibt keinen besseren Lebkuchen
als den meiner Frau.
Sicher?
- Nimmst du auch etwas Lebkuchen?
Vor 26 Jahren
sind sie auf die Welt gekommen,
und noch heute
haben sie täglich Kontakt:
die Zwillinge Martina und Melanie.
Wie waren die beiden so als Mädchen?
Zwillinge sind ja noch besonders.
Waren sie von Anfang an
eng verbunden?
Sie haben es ...
Es ist sicher sehr anstrengend,
wenn sie klein sind.
Aber später
hatten sie immer eine Freundin.
Sie konnten stundenlang spielen,
das war traumhaft für uns.
Wir mussten manchmal darum kämpfen,
dass sie am Wochenende rauskommen
und etwas machen.
Sie waren in ihrer Welt und ...
ja, wirklich.
Ab drei Jahren gibt es nichts
Schöneres für Eltern als Zwillinge.
Die haben gespielt ...
Manchmal trennt man sie in der Schule
extra. War das bei euch nie so?
In der Oberstufe.
Ja, aber wir wollten damals
in eine andere Klasse.
Frag mich nicht warum,
das war so eine blöde Entscheidung.
Es hat gar nichts gebracht,
alle Freunde
waren dann in Melanies Klasse.
In der Pause
war ich dann immer dort.
Es hat also nichts gebracht.
In der Oberstufe machten wir es
die letzten drei Jahre so.
Es hat uns
nicht auseinandergebracht,
wir sind auch nicht
selbständiger geworden.
Das Auseinandernehmen
bringt eigentlich gar nichts.
Ach, wirklich?
- Wirklich gar nichts.
Wir machten einmal den Fehler:
Wir nahmen eine Auszeit,
eine Woche in Mallorca,
fein essen, am Strand liegen,
fertig. Ohne Kinder.
Martina konnten wir beim Patenonkel
abgeben, Melanie bei der Patentante.
Also getrennt.
Sie müssen
eine Katastrophenwoche gehabt haben.
Sie wollte zu ihr, sie zu ihr,
und es war ein Riesengeschrei
die ganze Zeit.
Wir hatten eine schöne Woche,
wollten das aber nie wieder machen.
Jetzt werden sie bald auch getrennt.
Ja, das ist aber
ihre eigene Entscheidung. - Stimmt.
Jetzt wollen sie es so ...
Also, sie wollen es nicht,
aber das ist der Lauf der Zeit.
Darauf können wir keinen Einfluss
mehr nehmen.
Mhm.
Warst du mal sauer auf Martina,
weil du fandest ...
Dass sie das macht?
- Noch nicht.
Noch nicht, vielleicht,
wenn sie weg ist.
Nein, sauer ist vielleicht
der falsche Ausdruck.
Ich kann es voll und ganz
nachvollziehen, dass sie das macht.
Wäre ich in dieser Situation,
würde ich es auch so machen.
Nein, sauer nicht.
Man sagt, nach der Trauer kommt
die Wut, vielleicht wird es so.
Ich gehe aber nicht davon aus.
Nein, das bin ich nicht.
Das Einzige war, als Melanie ...
Sie kennt Sandro seit zehn Jahren?
- Im Sommer sind es zehn Jahre.
Sie hat ihn sehr jung kennengelernt.
Wir waren 16,
und ich hatte noch keinen Freund.
Da waren Sandro
und ich schon etwas ...
... Konkurrenz?
Ja, am Anfang
fand ich das nicht so toll.
Jetzt liebe ich ihn
wie einen Bruder.
* Drollige Klänge *
Bei so viel Harmonie
ist es auch kein Problem,
dass Martina und Cahil als Ehepaar
nochmals bei den Eltern eingezogen
sind, um Geld zu sparen.
In ein paar Monaten möchten die
beiden nach Australien auswandern,
in Cahils Heimat.
Wird es für Martina auch so schwierig
wie für dich in der Schweiz?
For her or for me?
- For her.
Ich glaube, sie wird
kaum Startschwierigkeiten haben.
Sie spricht jetzt schon
mit australischem Akzent.
Sie wird die Umstellung
gut meistern.
Wer hätte gedacht,
dass es doch etwas gibt,
das das gut geplante Leben
der Familie Stutz
schon bald auf den Kopf stellt?
Drunter und drüber statt hin und weg.
Liebe bedeutet sehr viel.
Aber am Ende muss man glücklich sein
und schauen,
was für sich selbst das Beste ist.
Dass man selbst glücklich ist
und nicht nur schaut,
dass es allen anderen
und dem Partner gut geht.
Es muss einem selbst gut gehen,
damit es allen anderen gut geht.
Ein Erfolgsrezept von Claudia und Kub
als binationales Paar könnte sein,
dass sie weder in seinem
noch in ihrem Land leben,
sondern in den USA.
Hier, wo beide ihre ganz
individuellen Erfolgsmomente haben.
Er als Basketballstar,
sie als Unternehmerin
und beide zusammen als Familie.
Anfangs mussten wir
einen Entscheid fällen.
Ich spielte als Profi,
sie tanzte in Los Angeles.
Wir mussten entscheiden, wer von uns
einen Schritt zurück macht,
um dem anderen zu folgen.
Sie gab ihren Traum für uns auf
und unterstützte mich.
Sie hat das ein paar Jahre gemacht.
Und jetzt versuche ich,
das Gleiche für sie zu tun.
Sie verfolgt jetzt
ihren Traum als Köchin
und ich folge ihr.
Dass sie zusammengehören,
war beiden schnell klar.
Und ähnlich spontan
kam die Entscheidung zur Heirat.
Das Stadthaus wollte
bereits schliessen, als wir kamen.
Alle Stars von Miami Heat
kamen zur Trauung,
und so liessen sie uns rein.
Alle wollten Autogramme
von Jermaine O'Neal, Dwyane Wade
und all den Jungs. Das war lustig.
Wir haben zweimal Hochzeit gefeiert.
Das war im Dezember.
Und im Juli noch mal.
Ja, morgen! - Am 10. Dezember?
- Morgen sind es zehn Jahre.
Das Strahlen in den Augen sieht man.
Ansonsten turteln die beiden
nicht gross in der Öffentlichkeit.
So wie er aufwuchs,
in seiner Familie,
zeigt man das nicht so öffentlich.
Auf der Strasse halten wir manchmal
Händchen oder küssen uns.
Aber nicht so ...
... innige Liebe, öffentlich.
Am Anfang war es schwierig,
aber jetzt ist es okay.
Jetzt sind wir wie Freunde -
die meisten wissen gar nicht,
dass wir verheiratet sind,
weil wir nie so tun.
* Relaxte Countryklänge *
Ow, don't squeeze so hard.
- I wasn't doing anything.
Es gewinnt nie jemand,
wir finden immer einen Kompromiss.
Wir beide sagen irgendwann:
"Ich habe überreagiert." "Ich auch."
Das ist das Schöne daran.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
was du gerade gesagt hast.
It was about who wins
when we have a fight.
I said that normally no one wins,
we always find a compromise.
And we always know
when we went too far.
Yes, I think so.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Als ich ein Junge war,
fischten wir da drüben.
Und als ich einen fing und ihn
hochziehen und abschneiden wollte,
schnitt ich mir in den Finger.
Es blutete und ich ging
zu diesem Hotel da drüben.
Ich blutete
und der Frau an der
Rezeption wurde es fast schlecht.
Südschweden
wird bald Florences neue Heimat.
Ihr Haus im Wald liegt etwas ausser-
halb der Studentenstadt Jönköping.
... moving festival,
they go to every city
and they have these big events.
Immer wieder,
wenn wir irgendwo durchgehen,
gibt es eine Geschichte dazu
oder er erklärt mir etwas.
Er ist ja hier aufgewachsen.
Das ist immer interessant.
Auch, wenn wir mit seiner Familie
unterwegs sind,
erzählen sie mir etwas.
Oder sie erklären etwas
zu einem Gebäude.
Man lernt nie aus.
Hallo, alles in Ordnung?
Geht es mit Salesse?
Gibst du ihr draussen etwas Futter,
okay?
Dann geht sie.
Gell.
Sag Oma einen Gruss.
Okay, tschüss, ciao, ciao.
Mit ihrer Tochter Noya
hat Florence regelmässig Kontakt,
wenn sie in Schweden ist.
Man ist sicher immer
etwas angespannt,
und fragt sich,
was wohl zu Hause los ist.
Es ist ja ein Grossteil der Familie
zu Hause.
Wenn etwas sein sollte,
und man so weit weg ist,
das ist sicher etwas ...
Es ist schwierig, damit umzugehen.
Fish and ...
Umso wichtiger
sind unbeschwerte Momente
in der Fernbeziehung des
schwedisch-schweizerischen Ehepaars.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
They're nice.
Wir nehmen es möglichst entspannt.
Wir haben zwar immer Pläne,
aber dann schauen wir,
wir lassen uns nicht stressen.
Wir wollen nicht zu viel
in ein Wochenende reinpacken.
Was wir heute nicht machen,
machen wir morgen.
Oder nächstes Mal.
- Or the next time.
Candies.
- Yes, candies.
Die Leute sind sehr offen
und unkompliziert.
Von der Mentalität her sind sie
nicht sehr anders als Schweizer.
Ich merke
keinen grossen Unterschied.
Aber wir dürfen am Sonntag
den Rasen mähen. - Yes.
Das war einschneidend.
Als ich ihm sagen musste,
dass wir sonntags nicht Rasen mähen.
Und nach 22 Uhr nicht mehr duschen.
Ich bot dir an, den Rasen zu mähen.
Doch du:
"Nein, nein, nein! Es ist Sonntag."
"Na und?" -
"Wir mähen nicht am Sonntag."
Da schau,
ein paar Wollsocken für Noya.
Or a hat? No, I think
we'll bring this for Katharina.
* Er spricht schwedisch. *
Ich muss meiner Tochter
immer welche bringen.
Sie liebt
diese dicken, warmen Socken.
An Weihnachten wollte sie unbedingt
einen Pulli mit Rentieren darauf.
Ich muss ihr immer solche Sachen
mitbringen.
Tack sa mycket.
Noya fliegt nicht,
das ist das Problem.
Laura möchte das nächste Mal
mitkommen.
Vielleicht im Sommer,
wenn sie an den Strand kann.
Ich glaube,
das passt den 22-Jährigen.
Das haben wir mal geplant.
Auch meine Mutter
möchte im Sommer mitkommen.
Dann können wir
die schönen Ausflüge machen,
wenn Hochsaison ist.
The sun is coming.
# Take my hand.
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
Spannend ist:
Was Claudia Diawara ursprünglich
nach Nordamerika brachte,
hat überhaupt nichts mit Catering
oder Kochen zu tun.
Sondern mit einem
ganz grossen Kindheitstraum,
den sie verwirklichen wollte:
mit dem Zirkus.
Nach ihren Anfängen in der Schweiz
besuchte Claudia mit 18
die Zirkusschule des Cirque du Soleil
in Montreal.
Den Traum einer Karriere als Artistin
musste Claudia
wegen einer Knieverletzung aufgeben.
Dafür hat sie in Amerika
den Mann ihres Lebens kennengelernt.
* Swing-Klänge *
Die USA: das Land der Möglichkeiten.
Und auch ein Land,
wo man die Gelegenheiten
beim Schopf packen muss,
wenn sie sich einem bieten.
Am Morgen ging ich ins Gym
und meine Freunde fragten,
was wir anschliessend machen.
Und ich sagte: "Ach, ich heirate."
"Heute?" Ich: "Ja, heute." -
"Hast du ein Kleid?" - "Nein."
Wo trifft man am Samstagmorgen
eine sportbegeisterte Familie?
Auf dem Trainingsplatz.
Are you ready?
* Funkige Klänge *
Too low.
* Funkige Gitarrenriffs *
* Hupen *
Hier trifft man euch.
- Hallo. - Ich bin Mona.
Hallo Mona, Claudia.
- Hallo, Claudia, das freut mich.
Alessia.
- Hello, I'm Mona, nice to meet you.
Hi. - How are you doing? Yakhouba.
- Good to see you, I'm Mona.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
Hi, you're Ariana. How is it going?
- Yes. - Good?
Ich weiss zwar, dass sich die beiden
in Los Angeles kennengelernt haben,
aber was war es genau,
das den 2-m-Mann am Anfang
so fasziniert hat an Claudia?
... that you said: "She's the one."
Zuerst fielen mir
ihre coolen Hosen auf.
Sie trug Männerjeans,
wie eine Hip-Hop-Musikerin.
Sie trug einen Hoodie
und diese UGG-Boots.
UGG-Boots?
Ja, die UGG-Boots
und so grosse Schlabberhosen.
Viel zu gross,
ich war damals sehr dünn.
Du hast nicht alles gemacht,
um ihm zu gefallen.
Nein.
- Um es mal so zu sagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich
kein Date mit ihm.
Aber alle sagten, er sei so nett.
Ich sagte: "Ja, okay, pff."
Ich habe mich
nicht extra schön gemacht.
Sie wollte gar kein Date mit dir.
Nein.
Blöd für dich.
Blöd für sie.
Wie hast du es geschafft,
sie umzustimmen?
Wir haben anfangs
miteinander geplaudert,
ihre Freunde hatten von ihr erzählt,
wir haben uns wieder getroffen.
Dann fingen wir an,
mehr miteinander zu sprechen,
erzählten einander von Paris,
von Zürich.
Es half mir, dass sie französisch
sprach, wie ich.
Weshalb seid ihr jetzt zusammen
und habt Kinder?
Wir haben uns gut verstanden
und immer mehr geredet.
Es hat sich so ergeben.
Schlussendlich
bin ich nach Denver gezogen.
Für ihn?
- Ja, für ihn.
Denver, Miami, Atlanta
und zwischendurch
immer wieder Besuche
in der Schweiz und in Frankreich.
Familie Diawara
führt ein internationales Leben.
Er spielte schon in der NBA.
Hast du überhaupt realisiert,
welchen Stellenwert das hier hat?
Nein, da ich aus der Schweiz bin,
wusste ich nicht,
was ein NBA-Spieler
oder ein professioneller Athlet ist.
Das sagte mir nichts.
Ich kenne Hockey und all das, aber
nicht die Ausmasse hier in Amerika.
Das wusste ich überhaupt nicht.
Als ich da reinrutschte,
dachte ich nur: "Ui, ui."
Ich musste erst lernen,
wie das geht.
Fandest du es anziehend,
dass sie eben kein Fan war?
Ja, sie kannte das nicht,
und das war gut.
Sie war nicht wie diese Leute,
die genau wissen,
was du tust und voller Bewunderung
zu dir kommen.
Nur so kannst du
die wahre Person sehen.
Ob du jemanden wirklich magst,
so wie er ist.
Und nicht, weil er der ist,
den die Leute im Fernsehen sehen.
Wir kommunizieren beide
nicht in unserer Muttersprache.
Da fällt es einem manchmal schwerer,
Emotionen oder Gefühle
in die richtigen Worte zu fassen.
Dort fehlt manchmal die Möglichkeit,
dem, was man wirklich sagen möchte,
den richtigen Boden zu geben.
* Sanftes Wellenrauschen *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Eigentlich wohnt Niklas
an einem wunderbaren Ort,
hier in Jönköping in Smaland.
Im Sommer ist es traumhaft,
dann hat man wirklich Meer-Feeling.
Auch wenn es nur ein See ist.
Am Sandstrand liegen und baden ...
Da hat man schon jedes Mal
ein schönes Ferien-Feeling.
* Lachen *
Hello.
Aber weil Florence nur in Kombination
mit sieben Hunden zu haben ist,
dürfte die Zeit am Stadtstrand
bald passe sein.
Niklas baut an der Zukunft.
Die liegt eine halbe Autostunde
weg von hier.
Man müsste sich nur
die rot-weissen Gebäude wegdenken,
dann könnte es auch
irgendwo in der Schweiz sein.
Vielleicht gibt einem das noch
ein bisschen Heimatgefühle.
Es sind nicht gerade Palmen und ...
So hat man das Gefühl,
noch in Europa
und in der Nähe der Heimat zu sein.
Und trotzdem
ist es irgendwie ganz anders.
In einem Wäldchen
an der Ostküste des Vätternsees
haben sie ein Stück Land gekauft.
Das ist unser Dörfchen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Etwas Stolz, etwas Aufregung,
ein paar Fragezeichen
und viel Vorfreude sind
bei Florence und Niklas zu spüren,
wenn sie ihr zukünftiges Zuhause
besuchen.
Unser neues Zuhause.
Als ich das letzte Mal hier war,
war alles noch dichter Wald.
Ich konnte
nicht einmal hier reingehen.
Es sah so aus wie dort drüben.
Ich habe seither Videos und Bilder
gesehen,
aber wenn man wirklich
auf dem Grundstück steht,
ist es noch mal ein anderes Gefühl.
Aber was zum Elch
bedeuten die Initialen N und B?
Die sind doch falsch?
Obwohl,
auf dem Arm trägt sie sie auch.
Am Anfang hatte er etwas Mühe
mit Florence.
Mein zweiter Vorname ist Isabelle.
Die Kurzversion ist Belle.
All seine Freunde und Familie
nennen mich so.
Deshalb hat sich das mit dem B
so eingebürgert.
Als sie das Fundament machten,
ritzte er das ein.
Lass uns zum Haus gehen.
Das hier ist die Garage.
Die Männerhöhle.
- Ja, meine Männerhöhle.
Silvans und dein Hobbyraum.
Ja, da werden keine Autos
erlaubt sein.
Keine Frauen.
Ich mache ein Schloss an die Tür.
Ja.
Here we are.
Hier ist der Eingang.
So, wir stehen im Haus.
- Yes.
Wir sind im Eingangsbereich.
Das wird die Hundedusche.
Hier kommst du dann rein, bringst
die Hunde rein, voller Dreck,
du bringst sie bis hierher.
Da gibt's eine Art Badewanne
für die Hunde, du steckst sie rein.
Duschen, abwaschen ...
Dann können sie ins Haus.
* Lachen *
Dafür liebt sie mich!
Weil ich solche Sachen mache.
Yes, that's why I love you,
because you do stuff like this.
Und hier ist deine,
Wasch... äh, unsere Waschmaschine.
Our ... It's my machine.
Hier kommen grosse Fenster hin,
die wir zur grossen Terrasse hin
öffnen.
Es ist für mich keine Einsamkeit
in der Natur.
Im Gegenteil:
Ich habe das Gefühl, man ist hier
fast in besserer Gesellschaft.
In der Gesellschaft der Natur.
Man hört die Vögel zwitschern,
Niklas sagte, dass letzte Woche
unten auf dem Feld Elche waren.
Wildschweine sind vorbeigerannt.
Wir werden unsere Hunde
und Tiere haben.
Nein. Ich habe mir oft
die Frage gestellt,
wie es ist, wenn man wirklich
hier draussen lebt.
Wenn ich heute hier stehe, muss
ich sagen: "Nein, überhaupt nicht."
Es ist eher ...
Es ist keine Einsamkeit,
es ist ein Frieden.
It's very peaceful.
- It's peaceful.
* Herzschlag *
Am Mittwoch, 18. März 2020,
geht es bei Martina und Cahil
plötzlich schnell.
Vor 24 Std. haben sie ihren Flug
nach Australien vorverlegt,
weil es nicht mehr anders ging.
Es ist jetzt
eine sehr überstürzte Abreise.
Wir haben ...
Das Coronavirus
ist gerade sehr aktuell.
Wir haben uns viele Gedanken
gemacht, was wir tun sollen.
Ob wir schon früher gehen sollen.
Wir haben den Flug zuerst
auf eine Woche vorher umgebucht.
Wir merkten aber, dass das
nicht reicht, um noch auszureisen.
Und vielleicht auch nicht,
in Australien einzureisen.
Gestern haben wir entschieden,
dass wir heute fliegen.
Ob sie noch bis Australien kommen
und wie gross die Ansteckungsgefahr
im Flieger ist: lauter Fragezeichen.
Man macht sich schon Gedanken ...
Man ist so vielen Menschen so nahe -
ich weiss nicht,
wie voll das Flugzeug sein wird.
Es ist ein anderes Gefühl,
man steigt mit einem anderen Gefühl
ins Flugzeug als ohne Virus.
Für uns war es sehr wichtig,
dass wir jetzt gehen konnten.
Es ist alles gekündigt, verkauft,
geplant auf diesen Monat.
Es wäre hart gewesen,
wenn es um ein halbes Jahr
verschoben worden wäre.
Wir planen das
seit eineinhalb Jahren.
Es wäre viel den Bach runter,
würde ich sagen.
Eigentlich wollte das junge Paar
erst an Ostern auswandern.
Jetzt blieb keine Zeit mehr,
um sich richtig von Freunden
und Bekannten zu verabschieden.
Immerhin ist die ganze Familie
zum Flughafen mitgekommen.
Für uns ist es auch
wie nach Hause reisen.
Ah. Oh nein,
wir wollten nebeneinander sitzen.
Sorry, danke, dass Sie das erwähnen.
Vielen Dank.
- (Frau) Eine gute Reise!
Danke, gleichfalls.
Habt ihr euch
hintereinander gebucht?
Oh mein Gott, Gotti.
Jetzt muss ich heulen.
Dürfen wir?
* Wimmern *
(Unter Tränen)
Du bist ja wahnsinnig.
Für einen Augenblick und eine
innige Umarmung ist Corona weit weg.
Vielleicht auch,
weil Martina und Cahil
beim Check-in beruhigende Nachrichten
erhalten haben.
Sie hat überprüft,
ob wir einreisen können
und nachgefragt, ob wir
einen australischen Pass haben.
Zum Glück sind wir verheiratet
und zählen als Familie.
Familienmitglieder dürfen einreisen.
Ich hoffe,
dass es morgen auch noch so ist.
Es dauert ja noch 24 Std.
So wie sie es sagte,
sollte alles klappen.
Du gehörst jetzt wirklich
zur Familie.
Hast du mich mal gesehen,
meine Augen sind so geschwollen
vom vielen Weinen.
Wir sehen auch ungekämmt gut aus.
Was meinst du,
wie wir in sechs Wochen aussehen.
Du siehst ungekämmt sowieso gut aus.
- Wenigstens mit dem Rasierer ...
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
* Unverständliche Worte *
Also, mach's gut, mein Schatz.
Pass auf dich auf.
Ich hab dich so lieb.
- Ich dich auch.
Tschüss.
Und dann gibt es kein Zurück mehr.
Melanie und Martina,
die unzertrennlichen Zwillinge,
haben schon bald
die ganze Weltkugel zwischen sich.
Du wirst mir fehlen.
Ich kann mir
gar nicht vorstellen ...
... dass du nicht mehr da bist.
* Tränenersticktes Gespräch *
Tschüss.
* Gefühlvolle Klavierklänge *
We don't have to leave just now.
Wer wohl in diesem coolen Haus wohnt?
Ein Mann, der hohe Räume braucht,
um aufrecht stehen zu können.
Vom Basketballprofi zum Hausmann.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Kann er kochen?
- Ja, er kann wirklich kochen.
Wie der Übergang von Claudias
tänzerischer Karriere ...
# Where I want it, baby.
... und Kubs sportlichem Grosserfolg
in den Familienalltag funktioniert,
sehen wir nächste Woche.
* Herzschlag *
... Identification card and ...
So you don't sneeze at each other.
Florence ist wegen Corona von
ihrem schwedischen Ehemann getrennt.
Wir haben uns das letzte Mal
vor fünf Wochen gesehen.
Im Moment wissen wir nicht,
wann wir uns das nächste Mal sehen.
Und wir sind dabei,
wenn Martina und Cahil in
letzter Sekunde ihr Ziel erreichen,
bevor auch in Australien
gar nichts mehr geht.
Heute um 21 Uhr könnten wir nicht
mehr nach Australien einreisen,
nur noch Australier.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me, take my hand.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2020